manuel macron lundi dans un documentaire
qui était diffusée lundi soir a déclaré
que le gouvernement n'avait jamais été
en rupture sur les masques il a défendu
ce qu'il a appelé une doctrine
restrictives qui était pour lui la bonne
chose à faire at il raison pour vous non
il a tort est ce qu'il a dit est faux
et j'affirme et il n'aurait pas dû le
dire il est président de république et
il devrait avoir un rapport à la vérité
plus transparent vis-à-vis des français
c'est important parce que quand on mène
un combat on doit inspirer la confiance
et le manque de confiance des français
puisque les français sont sans doute un
des peuples de l'europe qui est le plus
sceptique vis-à-vis ses dirigeants
vis-à-vis de la façon dont ils ont
conduit la lutte contre l'épidémie et je
pense qu' il peut y avoir des fautes
il ya eu une première faute
l'impréparation l'imprévoyance pas assez
de masquer tous les français le savent
et lorsqu'il dit que personne ne parlait
des masques notamment au mois de mars
est faux le personnel soignant en
hôpital dans les ehpad les médecins
généralistes les chirurgiens dentistes
tout le monde en parle capitable cas cet
exécutif rappelons le no no no no
m'attendais à ce qu'il dit vous
questionner sur ce qu'il est il a dit
très exactement qu'au mois de mars au
début mars
personne n'en parlait faux faux je
connais plein de médecins généralistes
qui n'étaient pas dotés en masse et les
français ont bien vu qu'il y avait cette
imprévoyance mais à cette première faute
d'un préparation il en ajoute une
seconde qui est le déni vis-à-vis de la
vérité il faut que la vérité et les
français le savent bien parce qu'ils ont
du bon sens bien non il ya eu un loupé
un énorme loupé de l'exécutif notamment
vis-à-vis des masques et le président de
république doit dire la vérité aux
français
il ne doit pas s'enferrer dans quelque
chose qui relève
je trouve vraiment d'une conception un
peu hasardeuse du rapport avec la vérité
c'est un mensonge
c'est un morceau joué